-Oh, my God, I'm really nervous.
Okay.
-[ Imitates gunshot ]
[ Quacks ]
-Good luck!
-I don't feel good.
-What are you talking about?
It's the first egg.
-I mean, I feel great.
-Usually --
The odds are in your favor
-You know, I'm doing
reverse psychology.
-Welcome to the show.
-I feel great about it.
-Good. I feel great, too.
Thank you for being here.
-Okay, ready?
-Yep. Yep.
-Oh!
♪♪♪♪
-I'm here with Anna Kendrick
and we are about
to go head-to-head in a game
of Egg Russian Roulette.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-Yes, James.
Here in my hand,
I have one dozen eggs.
-Mm-hmm.
-Eight of them
have been hard-boiled.
-Uh-huh.
-Four of them are still raw,
uncooked, untainted by fire.
[ Laughter ]
You and Anna will take turns
selecting one egg at a time,
uno ovum, and smashing the
upon the top of your head.
-Uno ovum.
-You won't know which eggs
are raw and which aren't,
but once you choose,
you may not unchoose.
You must smash that egg
upon your head.
First one to smash two raw egg
on their head loses.
Anna, as a lovely guest
of the show,
you will choose the first egg.
[ Howls ]
-Okay.
Oh, my God.
I'm really nervous.
Okay.
-[ Imitates gunshot ]
[ Quacks ]
-Good luck!
-I don't feel good.
-What are you talking about?
It's the first egg.
-I mean, I feel great.
-Usually --
The odds are in your favor
-You know, I'm doing
reverse psychology.
-Welcome to the show.
-I feel great about it.
-Good. I feel great, too.
Thank you for being here.
-Okay, ready?
-Yep. Yep.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well played.
James, choose wisely.
-Do I go to the one
next to yours?
I can't wait to go see
your movie this weekend.
It's gonna be so fun, and
I'll bring my hard-boiled eggs
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho!
-The odds increase.
-Okay.
Women don't usually --
Am I the first woman to do eggs?
-You're actually the first
woman to play this game
and dare play this game.
You called it. I was like,
"You want to call me out.
Let's do it, girlfriend."
-Alright. Alright.
You know why? You know why
-Why?
-'Cause I've got eggs.
-[ Laughs ] What?
-Oh, my stomach hurts.
-[ Laughs ] Higgins.
-It makes sense.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-You do.
-It's a lot of smack talk...
-Oh, is there?
For someone
who's about to smack,
and then I'm about to talk
[ Imitates smashing ]
Good to see you.
You look beautiful.
-Thanks, buddy.
-Yep.
-Oh.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You may have eggs.
But I have...
-Don't. Don't say it.
-Okay, don't say it.
-Don't say it.
Tom Brady's got deflated.
Pick, Jimmy!
-Yes!
-One of these eggs
has your name on it.
The fates have it written.
Good luck.
-Oh, no!
I don't feel good about this
Oh!
"Pitch Perfect,"
Pitch Perfect 2"!
Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You look so pretty.
You look so pretty.
-The yolk's on you.
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Gosh.
-Choose wisely.
-You can't hear it.
[ Laughs ]
There's not a prize inside
-You look pretty.
-Or maybe there is.
Maybe you can hear it.
-You look great.
-Good luck.
I hope you look great
at your premiere tonight.
It'll be so good.
Thank you so much.
-I'm such a big fan of the show.
-Oh, good, me too.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Whimpering ]
I have something in my throat.
-Oh, yeah.
-[ Imitates spritzing ]
-I think this is
an egg-cellent choice.
Whoa!
[ Laughs ]
It's getting sticky.
It's getting sticky!
-The odds are now 50/50,
three cooked, three raw.
[ Laughter ]
Oh!
-I really don't feel good
about this.
I really don't.
-You really don't.
-I really don't.
Just go for it.
-It's fine. It's fine.
Egg's a natural conditioner.
I'm not even mad.
-Yep. Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're so confident
going in and so --
Oh, stop it.
Like you meant to do that.
Oh, please.
It actually looks good.
It looks like a headband.
Alright, Higgins.
Where are we at now?
What is the math?
What's the math on this?
-Two raw, three cooked.
-Alright.
-The odds are in your favor.
-They are.
-Unless you choose mistakenly.
Two eggs --
-What country are you from
-Cracker Barrel.
Ooh.
-[ Breathing rapidly ]
-Oh!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
-Thank you so much.
-Anna Kendrick is the champion
-You are the champion and
the best for playing this game
We love you.
Oh, my gosh. Anna Kendrick
I'm here with Zac Efron.
"We Are Your Friends,"
August 28th.
We're about to go head-to-head
in a game of
Egg Russian Roulette.
Higgins, would you like
to explain how this works?
-Yes, James.
-What the...
-Here in my hands,
I have one dozen eggs.
Eight of them
have been hard-boiled.
-Eight of them.
-Four of them are still raw.
You and Zac will take turn
smashing one egg at a time
upon the top of your head.
You won't know which eggs
are raw and which ones
[laughing] are hard-boiled
Once you choose an egg,
you must smash that egg
upon the top of your head,
no put-backs.
First one to smash two raw egg
on their head loses.
Zac, as a guest on this show
you will choose the first egg.
-Ooh, I'm gonna go base--
I feel like I'm in
the last scene of "Deer Hunter
right now.
-No, this is more fun.
-Choose wisely.
-Let's see.
Man, what happens to them
when they're...?
-I know.
Don't go by the lighting
either.
I'm gonna try
and move my shadow around.
-Good luck.
-I feel --
You can kind of tell.
I'm pretty positive
this one's...
-You can't. You can't tell
-Really?
-I have played the game before
Yeah.
-You can't tell?
-This is what makes it fun
Yeah. You can't tell.
-And you've just got
to go for it.
-Yeah, good to see you, buddy.
-I have no fear of eggs.
-Nope.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You put it there.
Oh, no!
-You did that no looking.
-I know. It kind of feels like
there's something goopy in here.
[ Breathing heavily ]
Oh.
-You did the last one
no looking,
so I'm just going
to go for this guy right here.
-Yeah.
-Oh, no, this one is wet.
I already know it's wet.
-You know it.
-I can already tell.
-Then go for it,
give it a good one, man.
-Alright.
-There you go.
-I loved this suit before.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-How can you tell?
You felt it?
-I felt it shaking around
in there. I knew it.
-Oh, no, the suit is trashed
-Is the suit trashed?
-You can send us
the dry-cleaning bill.
No, it's fantastically
dripping all over the place.
Please get a shot of it
oozing down there.
That's great, okay, good.
-Good, good.
-Whoo!
-Don't whoo for him.
He gets whooed,
he's just egg on his...
Alright, here we go.
Thank you, Higgins.
-You're welcome.
Yay.
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Doing good.
-This is fantastic. It's alway
great to see you, man.
-I think I'm about to come back.
I don't know
how you come back from this.
-It's always great to see you,
man. This is so fun.
-It feels like it's Easter
I should be painting these
but instead
I'm cracking them on my head
-Yes, this is great.
-I feel good about this one.
Sweet.
♪♪♪♪
-I'm gonna use that confidence
I'm gonna be like you,
just confident.
-Do it.
-Feel great about this one
This one is cool.
-It's a good egg.
-No, this one feels like
something is going on.
-Something's shaking?
-[ Yelling gibberish ]
Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-That was -- That was really
cool in slow motion.
That was really cool
in slow motion.
-Alright, here we go.
-A one in three chance.
Two left that are raw.
-What's wrong with you?
Why are you off
to the side weird?
-[ Accent ] And vat is the
accent that you're doing?
[ Normal voice ]
I'm gonna go for it.
-Good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have so much egg
on your face...
literally.
-And figuratively.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
[ Laughing ]
[ Yelling gibberish ]
-Oh!
-You got to be kidding me, man
-Zac is the champion!
-How am I the champion?
-Zac's the winner right there.
The winner, Zac Efron.